how do I belong this is hideous eternal
they may cry five direct and I'm the
producer of Devil May Cry 5 Matt Walker
and today we're gonna be showing you
guys a little bit of gameplay from Devil
May Cry 5 and specifically going over
different decisions we made in terms of
game design specifically for the second
play through the game I'm gonna be
off-camera providing some translation as
well as commentary of my own but you can
look forward to seeing eternal Sun here
on camera as we're doing it's
interesting because the approach that we
took for Sun of Sparta as a difficulty
was that we wanted that to be the
difficulty where people who were good at
the game we're gonna have the most of
all that was really something that we
had a lot of focus on because we had
played the game and that was really for
us to be able to say oK we've played the
game enough we're this good at the game
now we're gonna be able to place on a
Sparta and it should be just the right
difficulty where it's a ton of fun for
us
going to that second player and you'll
also notice we have stronger enemies
appear in these stages that weren't
originally in these stages for the devil
hunter difficulty on devil hunter it
would actually be really hard had these
enemies showed up because this is the
second run-through and ends up just
adding a lot and making a little more
fun because people have gotten a little
better at the game at that point and
this is one of these enemies where we
very specifically set up a pattern in
mind where if you don't fight it a
certain way it can be pretty difficult
in the way that we've set this enemy up
with other enemies and that is with
desta's there's very specific timing
where when the scissors gleam if you
time your attack so that you attack at
the same time as death scissors then
you'll knock Desa jizz off their guard
and then you can shoot them for a
one-hit kill this critical hit you
really want to do that because if you
don't no matter how many times you hit
death scissors it's gonna be pretty hard
to actually do any damage and all the
while you have other enemies also trying
to attack you and you can get into some
pretty big crowd control problems if you
don't take him out that well this was
the battle that we kind of decided from
the get-go was going to be the one that
we use in the demo the the vertical
slice boss the one that we were going to
put the most love into to really set the
bar for this is what boss battles in
this game
be like moving forward looking me off no
there I wanted to make sure that we
created something that really took me as
much advantage the hardware as possible
and something that was visually stunning
that's why you have for instance you
just circled the bell tower there the
idea that this bell tower is
destructible if a boss say runs into it
or is thrown into it that's destructible
and we also have a guy on the team let's
kind of talk he's not do a fantastic job
with all the physics this game is
supposed to run at six games per second
at 4k physics calculations when you have
a ton of little objects running that can
get process intensive our guy did this
fantastic job of finding ways to fake
certain aspects but then at a result we
get a lot of really great physics
simulations another thing about this
fight is really there are three stages
to you start off on the top of the
church you fall down into the Cathedral
and then you break out and come out into
the parking lot here right we just
wanted to provide as much variety and as
much as make it as visually stunning as
possible and that's why this battle and
the way it did but there's still a lot
of stuff for this boss too and for all
the bosses in the game where we had to
think about what's it gonna be like when
you play against him the second time
through is there any new stuff you can
do because you're gonna have new moves
and have new double breakers that you
wouldn't have had at this point in the
game on the first playthrough so for
instance you usually don't have the
Buster arm double breaker in this battle
but for the second time through they're
finally going to have that and so we've
added and stuff like the obvious one is
the fact that you can actually use the
Buster arm and actually throw him but
for instance you can do a counter Buster
when the Goliath is coming at you the
time that Buster press just right you'll
then stop him and you'll get a really
cool animation and counter move from
that as well there's different Buster's
you can do like when you're inside the
church so outside of the church he does
the kind of airplane throw it takes him
by the tail and throws him right but in
the church there's a different Buster
that you can do it's more of he's just
kind of beating the crap out of him with
his arms that boss fight one of the cool
things about it too is because we have
these different environments that you're
fighting in that also helps to teach
players how they can use certain weapons
for instance one of the most effective
things you can do is once you're down in
the church is pedal reading all the
lasers bounce off the wall and by doing
that every single time one of those
lasers bounce off the wall and hits the
Goliath it does more and more damage and
that's really effective for that so also
providing a place where if players
experiment they can
there's stuff that they can do with
their current weapons that's really
effective on the ball fountain each
human is imaging and for Dante's second
playthrough we really focused on okay
how can we get players to play with sin
Majin Dante levelled up Devil Trigger
form there and then how can they use
that kind of in coordination with Mach
and not David double sword down
especially if it's in Majin Dante the
way that that works is you have to hold
in the double trigger button to charge
up this other double trigger gauge is in
Majin gauge there it's kind of a waste
if you have a full double trigger gauge
and you're not doing that because you
could be doing that you could be
charging it up and it's really best for
players to try and keep that sim Majin
gauge full so they can pull that off
when everything gets in complete order
the theme for the stage itself is
usually there's these catacombs we
actually went visited really cool
catacombs in London for reference and
they're kind of catacombs where the
cliff off has started to penetrate and
the demon world is starting merged with
these catacombs here the interesting
thing about the game design of the stage
is that it's it's one of the stages in
the game where you actually have a
couple different paths and you have one
path where you could go through and
you'd actually have you'd use up all
your nidhogg hatchlings and then one
where you'd actually have one left but
we're also kind of afraid that by doing
this by giving people the choice to kind
of explore a little bit that they could
get lost so you can see these grooves in
the ground try to keep those grooves
there to kind of help direct people and
as you go through the stage you'll
destroy cliath roots and then this
stream of blood will essentially come
streaming down those and that also kind
of helps direct the point can you talk
more about your trip to London it was me
and the senior producer and a couple of
the artists kind of all went to London
if you eat samosa it's been a lot of too
many times because he worked with ninja
theory on team she doesn't make cry and
that's also really part of how we ended
up going with London as a base for this
fictional city here as well you have
this beautiful architecture where
everything from the what you guys would
call the first floor up you have a lot
of beautiful like Gothic architecture
stuff that you can feel the history of
right Gothic architecture is kind of one
of the themes that we have as well as
death death is another thing that
makes double men cry what it is you
should kind of feel death in different
elements and we thought that
architecture that you can feel that
history from would really mesh well with
that kind of gothic feeling and then
also in London you have the obviously it
was just all kind of people there right
that would be a great way to show a city
where having a bunch of people in it
makes it feel alive you see that you
know kind of during the opening
cutscenes and whatnot Antonio das and
actual the important thing is to give
players lots of choice and so that means
really giving them a whole bunch of
moves I can understand where people
might think that ok because I have all
these moves this is overwhelming but
what we're trying to do is give them as
many moves as possible so that they have
choice and it's okay if they don't use
all the moves when designing the enemies
specifically it's an asylum want to make
sure that there was at least two ways to
approach any specific enemy so for
instance for these guys beauty with fury
base way that you you want to play
against them regardless of whether
you're down to your knee row or whatever
you'll notice that they will always
attack right after the war so you want
to try to get down that timing for the
war and once you get down that timing
what you want to do is you want to try
to evade that attack and then hit them
as soon as you're done evading for Dante
for instance you also have the ability
to suppress SP use Kerberos Kerberos is
a weapon that can stun enemies pretty
well so you can always use Kerberos to
kind of knock down the guard and then
you laugh but again the idea that you
want to give people as much choice as
possible so that they feel like they're
approaching the enemy on their own terms
the kilobyte autocar their bassist a
host I cannot oh do you remember the
moment where you were playing play
testing and going okay this is it it's
locking into place there are a couple
different times where we felt that there
were different stages and so the first
one was about a year after we started
making the game there was a point where
we were all kind of watching as Dante
had this animation and game where he
would kind of hop backwards as he's
moving and shooting ebony and ivory at
the same time and we noticed you know
the way he's hopping the way his feet
are contacting with the floor correctly
the way that both his hair and the coat
are kind of flapping in the wind
everything was kind of coming together
and was starting to look right
and that's when the itõs on filters felt
like okay this is gonna work then one
okay there's another time
it's about October of 2017 where we
decided to kind of make an internal
trailer something we be able to kind of
use internally to kind of show to the
higher-ups and maybe even show first
party everything that's in the game to
help explain like what the game is as a
product you watch that and we're like
okay this is good this looks like a game
that I want to buy and then from that
point on we still had a year where we
were just constantly tuning everything
so that it would end up at the final
quality so you mean the back then you
know in October of 2017 it still wasn't
really at the kind of quality that we
Capcom would feel confident in putting
out was that anything perhaps from
previous games that you weren't able to
do or an idea that was cut that ended up
in Devil May Cry 5 the biggest one is
cavalier the idea that let's have a
motorcycle weapon we had you know the
guitar weapon and double May Cry 3 for
instance these kind of outlandish
weapons ever since definitely cried to
they've wanted to do a bike weapon you
know at the very end of the make I do
Dinah kind of rides out on a motorcycle
don't make cry three they were hoping to
get a motorcycle weapon in there but
kind of due to time and budget
constraints that didn't happen but
there's this cutscene where Dante grabs
the motorcycle as he's falling down the
tower and he uses the motorcycle like
nunchucks that's kind of a remnant of
that idea that hey let's have a
motorcycle weapon here with democratic
five it was finally time to kind of come
up with the different weapons for him
and everyone thought we got to do the
motorcycle
so let's come up with some ideas for
that and so there's this guy who was one
of the main animators on the devil may
cry she was definitely the maker at four
who you just had a picture of Dante
holding to has a motorcycle in both arms
like that like we're doing that that is
what the motorcycle weapon is I saw the
beginning of the idea for making double
May Cry 5 really came from he's no son
seeing that we haven't had a whole lot
of what we considered these pure action
games in recent matters he really wanted
to make that kind of game and kind of
bring it to everybody and go look what
makes action fun hasn't changed the last
thing I want to kind of show everybody
that you know you can still have this
kind of game and it's still something
that people can enjoy and kind of remind
people how much fun this is none of the
games up we get a chance to actually see
you know what everybody's saying about
on Twitter
everywhere and we very specifically see
people go oh man this is great I haven't
played a game like this in a while so
it's really great to kind of have that
validation this is exactly what we were
going for this is what we truly believed
to be something that would be worthwhile
ethos on is ecstatic to finally see that
come to fruition
[Music]